(playful piano music)
(soft whirring)
- [Bruce] Ralph Waldo Emerson once quoted
that nothing great can ever be
achieved without enthusiasm.
I have a lot enthusiasm.
- [Announcer] This Great Big Story
was made possible by Geico.
Believe it.
Geico could save you 15%
or more on car insurance.
(joyful music)
- This is Northlandz in
Flemington, New Jersey.
Northlandz is the world's
largest model railroad.
Well, I guess, you know,
everybody has a passion for something.
My thing was trains.
Had trains around the
Christmas tree as a kid.
Wherever I lived, I'm
planning track plans;
and then over 18 years,
I added five basements onto the house.
From that, I got fairly
good at making mountains
and bridges and design-work,
and we decided to give it to the world,
so we tour it all down, bought this land,
and built Northlandz.
Any given day, we run
between 85 and 90 trains.
Some of the details in Northlandz inside:
about 40,000 feet of track;
about 4,000 buildings;
over 400 bridges;
many of the mountains in here
are three and a half stories high.
Most things in here are scratch-built.
Underneath the entire super structure,
there's enough lumber to
build about 42 large houses.
Takes a few hours to go
through for the average person
to see everything.
We went millions into
debt to build this place.
Everybody thought we were nuts,
and the only one that believed
in what I wanted to do
was my wife, and she was totally
with me on this big time.
It's an artistic endeavor;
it's a gift to the world of what I can do,
and it makes a lot of people happy.
(emotional music)